welcome back to another episode of
trendy versus traditional where we do
two different versions of the same dish
and it is so hot today that we are both
craving the same thing we're craving
ice cream today i'm just gonna be making
a really simple straightforward
traditional ice cream from scratch and
i'm very excited for the end result i'm
also very excited but the ice cream i'm
making today i can't make it here so
you're leaving i am leaving because i
need a certain equipment and we don't
have it here so i am going to go
off-site
okay
starting to sweat
good luck good luck i'll see you i guess
later okay so yeah you're leaving
i have to admit i'm sweating a little
bit because inka is very good in the
kitchen just in general but i think
she's exceptionally good at desserts i'm
not super experienced making ice cream
so i'm gonna ask everyone at home to
please bear with me as you can see i am
in a different kitchen i really wanted
to do something special today i wanted
to do these things called rolled ice
cream i first saw these on youtube
videos of these street food stalls in
thailand where they would make these ice
cream rolls also known as stir-fried ice
cream which i thought was super cool
that's why i'm here at -10 ice cream
they specialize in rolled ice cream i
have my ingredients laid out i'm gonna
make the mixture first and then after we
make the mixture we can start rolling
yeah okay going into the saucepan first
is one cup of whole milk
i'm also confident that i will not make
a mess during this shoot and step number
two is it's a cup and a half of heavy
cream and we're gonna measure out oh
baby that's thick this is just gonna be
like dairy soup that's gonna
get nice and
thick
you can see how thick that is that is
like
plopping off of that that's a bad choice
of words in terms of ingredients fairly
simple we only have four things milk
sugar pasteurized eggs and heavy
whipping cream so you don't always need
to put eggs in your ice cream but adding
eggs makes it creamier it gives it like
a richer texture which is why we're
gonna do it because i like my ice cream
cream is that gross
i like my ice cream creamier all right
so let's get pouring so first off i'm
gonna put the milk in
and then sugar
and the eggs
this is just pasteurized egg yolks give
this a little bit of a stir
just to make sure the sugar is well
integrated i think that's about good so
now i'm just gonna add the whipping
cream
again just mixing that together so now
we have our cream mixture
boom then we want a quarter cup of sugar
said i wasn't gonna make a mess oh he's
getting cocky he's getting cocky uh
that's okay i'll get it later oh god put
our quarter cup of sugar into our like
dairy stew here
this recipe is so simple
that i can't mess up i can't just gonna
pour this straight back into this cup
now that i have my mixture done i'm
gonna move over to the station where we
have our ice cream machine and uh i'll
take it from there i've never worked
with vanilla beans before and i can tell
this is serious business because there's
only three of them in a jar which to me
means a little goes a long way this is
where some dexterity comes into play
getting surgical everyone's holding
their breath
whoa
the bean is split now it's time to
harvest uh i'm gonna choose a different
word than harvest it makes me sound like
i'm an alien
now it's time to
extract the seeds you only get one shot
i don't think i've ever
seen vanilla beans and like vanilla for
these seeds it smells like really
intense vanilla which makes sense we're
gonna go ahead and add that
last thing is to just cut this pod in
half and we're gonna drop those into our
stew here and then bring this to a
simmer there's a lot of crazy flavors we
could do but i decided to go with fruity
pebbles so i know i'm responsible of
doing like trendy food but this is the
first time i'm actually doing rainbow
food so that's pretty exciting i also
think like a bit of cereal in your ice
cream will also give it that extra
crunch it's like creamy but there's also
like little crunchy bits i feel like it
should pair pretty well it's going to
look really pretty this recipe i'm going
to use four egg yolks one of my concerns
with this is i don't want it too eggy
these are some juicy boys
take it easy this is a little bit
intimidating i'm not gonna lie don't
really have a lot of experience doing
this
wish me luck let's do this
concentration bit of honey on here
hopefully that's not too much and then
in goes our
mixture this is the part
where we have to go really fast
so you have to go fast because the
griddle is freezing the ice cream and if
you don't do this it might get stuck to
the surface it's like when you get
freezer burn right from your ice creams
this is what they did in like the street
food videos too so
that's my inspiration
it's like scrambling eggs a little bit
ice cream is just delicious and it's
delicious because of the sugar and we're
gonna get another quarter cup of sugar
in with the yolks here just to combine
all of this
ultimately we're not looking for this to
be super yellow
and this is getting a little paler uh so
i think i just need to keep going on
this for another minute or so
[Music]
oh god i need a gatorade or something
the yellowness has definitely come
pretty far down it is starting to turn a
little bit paler which is what we want
oh okay i'm done my forearm is on fire
so now i have my
little ice cream pile
we're supposed to spread this out now
into like a thin
even layer you want to get to get it as
thin and even as possible because then
you can roll it out properly
and it has to be even so you don't get
like
weird looking
chunks is it time to now roll i think it
is
here we go i'm gonna set this down
and roll this baby it's time to rock and
roll
okay
[Music]
boom they said to hold it up tilt this
up high
really putting my arm muscles to work
here welcome back we have let our cream
vanilla bean mixture cool a little bit
that's very important because we're
gonna be pouring it into our like egg
mix and we don't want the hot liquid to
cook the eggs no one wants scrambled
eggs ice cream we're mixing a half a cup
of our cream mixture into the egg
mixture get that all combined the
thickening
my arm is going to be so
ripped by the end of today if you're not
making this face
we'll make an ice cream
you're not doing it right
now that our egg and cream mixture are
combined it's not hot it's just like
slightly warm which we're going to pour
this back into our saucepan
we're going to bring the temperature up
a little bit just looking to thicken
this a little more over some heat here
he goes
i'm happy to say it is very very good
right now it just tastes like a melted
vanilla milkshake which to me means i'm
definitely on the right track okay so
now i have my five little mini ice cream
rolls
i'm just gonna put this in the bottom
gently just pile this on i'm holding it
at an angle so then you know it's easier
to put this together so this is what i
have
this is my semi-finished product it
didn't turn out as bad as i thought it
would be i'm pretty happy i'm gonna fill
this bowl with ice
i'm gonna pour the hot mixture into this
and then set that down and we're gonna
like chill it as fast as we can before
it gets
churned up this is pretty much it i'm
gonna pour it into the ice cream maker
and in theory we will then have vanilla
bean ice cream this is gonna sit in here
for about 30 minutes it's gonna turn
into ice cream i will then scoop it out
and then go find inga so we can figure
out traditional versus trendy which ice
cream is better before this melts i'm
gonna now quickly prepare the toppings
[Music]
i found you i need to finish plating
this all right please give me something
all right i'm gonna oh
okay i'll be i'll be back
[Music]
bring it on we have malin and i love ice
cream we have to apologize a little bit
there they've gotten a little melty it's
a little steamy in new york i like
melted ice cream too so i present to you
my vanilla bean ice cream sundae please
enjoy it looks very classic fast casual
nerd that is very much my beat and i'm
sticking to vanilla i feel like is very
american thank you
i don't know why
oh that's really good actually
actually
despite its appearance it's really
creamy okay that's what i was aiming for
now i'm gonna try this one i've never
had rolled ice cream before so i'm
excited to try it
oh you really taste the fruity pebbles
yeah yeah yeah crunchy
which is like a nice thing in ice cream
i feel like the presentation is
beautiful yes i love strawberries so
that helps i'm sweating and it's not
because it's hot
we will respectfully hold our ice creams
given presentation
i think
angus was prettier but
in terms of taste i'm much more like of
a classic ice cream kind of person so i
think i'd have to say chris's is my
favorite crying crying interestingly
this is the hardest i've worked on a
traditional recipe
so i will take that but
i think this was a very very fair
apparently
it was hard
this is like yeah but this is good
there's no hard feelings in this battle
we get to eat just good food that we
make for each other as usual tell us in
the comments below what you want us to
do next or dms find us on instagram let
us know until next time cheers
[Music]